c'est l'une des villes qui a connu le
plus de bombardements depuis la guerre
mais après deux mois de résistance c'est
vers donetsk devrait tomber aux mains
des forces russes et leurs alliés
l'armée ukrainienne a reçu l'ordre de se
retirer selon le gouverneur de la
province de louhansk
ça n'a pas de sens de maintenir nos
positions pendant des mois juste pour le
principe de rester aucune précision
n'est donnée sur les modalités du
retrait ces derniers jours les soldats
et craignant ne contrôle et qu'une
infime partie de la ville notamment
l'usiné azote dans une zone industrielle
selon les autorités régionales
568 civile s'y trouvaient encore jeudi
après la conquête de plusieurs villages
ces dernières heures les forces
pro-russes menace d'encercler la zone
regroupant severodonetsk et sa ville
jumelle licite chance qu en cas de
succès elle contrôlerait la totalité de
la province de lougansk dans le donbass